good morning John my new office is set
up over here we have the games with Hank
and over here we have vlogbrothers and
over here is my actual desk where I fit
this is just a picture of you
what's your puff is a bird I'll put it
fullscreen so everybody can see okay
John it's kind of easy to forget how
cool the things we get to do are I get
to have a channel where I just play
video game you could have a fictional
soccer team that helps fund a real
soccer team we get to work in a new
medium that despite what people who work
in it say no one understands or knows
what to do win crash course is now being
used as a tool in literally thousands of
schools just hang out with Bill Gates a
guy who would be the richest person in
the world if he hadn't given so much of
his money away and just talked about the
complexities of market forces on rural
agriculture in Ethiopia what and in the
last like four days this community has
raised 260 thousand dollars to help
people who don't have access to clean
water get access to clean water I spent
some time this week watching those
donations come in and the most common
thing people say they get to leave a
comment if they want to is I'm sorry I
couldn't give me and I don't spend
enough time thinking about how amazing
this is it the weird and wonderful
position that has been granted to us by
two things one pure dumb luck and to the
people who are watching this right now
just like I kind of get used to how I
get to do cool stuff now people who are
a part of things or who watch things
forget that they're the reason that the
thing exists by spending time watching
this video you are granting me power and
it's kind of weird to me that in a world
of infinite content where there's 30
rock and Breaking Bad and PewDiePie and
cat videos that you choose to watch this
what what why time is a gift and I am
honored that you give it to me let's
also have a little bit of real talk here
I am still insecure
I still like get sad sometimes I don't
struggle with depression I don't think I
just have a normal amount of sadness and
sometimes I don't want to do stuff and
feel unmotivated and undeserving of the
things that I have and I think that's
rational like I don't there's nothing
special about me that means that people
should be watching me on the internet I
don't deserve it but the
that I don't want to feel is that I'm
faking it somehow feeling like you don't
deserve success being sad sometimes
those are normal but they're not really
socially acceptable to talk about so I
figured but more socially acceptable is
saying I'm so overworked to work all the
time and I'm overwhelmed which I am
there's a lot of things we could be
doing with our time and resources but I
don't know what to do that decision is
really hard it occurred to me today
that's a lie it didn't occur to me John
actually said it to me on the phone when
we were talking that I should just ask
you're the reason all this exists what
do you think we should do so I made a
survey you can rank different things
that we might want to do in order of
what how much you think we should do
them and then add if you have other
ideas for what we should do with the
power of this community that's like why
didn't like what's wrong with me that I
didn't think of that before I have an
amazing community that's supporting all
of the things we're doing why don't I
ask them but you make the decision I
don't want to that sounds hard so yeah I
was feeling a little down yesterday that
happens I think to everyone I'm feeling
better now on the list of things that
I'm grateful for because of this thing
that's pretty high up there this is
always there for me to be a thing that I
need to do to motivate me to get out of
bed to make a thing to be a part of
something thanks John I'll see you on
Tuesday
Hey did you like that you like
smashmouth is that better
so the RVT